Annabelle merci d'être là Annabelle de
viledieu votre nom on dirait un je te
jure il y a un truc de ouf Annabelle de
villeedieu je suis Annabelle de
villeedieu normalement tu arrives comme
je suis Annabelle de
viledieu descendante des
rougemonds oui moi Annabelle de vilieu
je vous
conchie vous êtes une noble et oui non
c'est vrai ou de viledieu c'est
Charlemagne Charlemagne ouais ça remonte
c'est clair ça remonte à qui Louis 6 le
gros Louis 6 le gros et oui gros
pourquoi le gros pourquoi le
gros parce que à l'époque à l'époque les
gars tu vois maintenant un gars non mais
avant à l'époque il y avait aucune gne
tu vois il y a Louis 6 le
GR dis-moi tu as des nouvelles de
Charles le CHUM il y a Charles le chum
qui arrive après aussi ouais ouais
dis-moi il y a Louis le dégueulasse
aussi qui arrive
les gars NZ sans Batz les Ys total tu
vois ou pas ah ah fils de ça
vai c'est bon non mais c'est vrai c'est
ouf sans déconner et donc toi tu étais
de Louis 6 Louis 6 le gros ouais voilà
quoi il mchit Dieu
bénisse non c'était le gros parce que ah
parce qu'à l'époque c'était comme ça
d'accord donc un gars ouais ou d'accord
ok euh bah très bien on nom met avec
apparence physique vous nommer ici comme
à l'époque tu vois ben tu vois don qu je
vais vous dire si ça va donner faut pas
demander faut pas demander non mais
c'este Bonel le
Branleur si j'aime que ça de la tour du
pain
l'imposteur g le suc il
arrive non mais voilà pas tu veux
quelque chose toi non merci
c'est c'est bon tu en assez pris pendant
les vacances alors Annabelle juste parce
qu'on est 2024 hein et oui ça Filoche
euh j'ai très envie de savoir ce qui va
se passer déjà cette année est-ce qu'il
va y avoir encore euh des des bails de
ouf genre des covid ou des bails comme
ça alors 2024 ça va pas être une année
facile c'est clair va être ah bah oui
moi je dis ce que je ressens ça va être
dans la ligné de 2023 waouhce
la waouh Annabelle et pour moi on n'aura
pas quelque chose qui va s'améliorer
avant le 2026 mais ça vousavis déjàé
je me bar je me barre salut les gars
ride
merci c'est tout pour moi j c'est vrai
quoi 2026 oui non c'est une année
difficile 2024 année de transition une
année d'entre mais toutes les années
sont des années de transition j'ai
l'impression la vache oui mais là voilà
jusqu'en 2026 pour moi ça va être un peu
difficile encore c'est quoi il va y
avoir quoi des je vois beaucoup d' Meux
de gens dans les rues il y aura beaucoup
de manifestations et puis avec les
problèmes au niveau aussi de de la
guerre pour moi il y aura beau beaucoup
de ou mer aussi de conflit en fait et
beaucoup d'attentats sur la France cette
année pêche en tout cas merci d'être
venuit pas une année facile c'est bien
parce la prochaine fois je demande à
Gill Verdez non mais Annabelle tu as
raison de dire la vérité ma ch c'est
vrai franchement regarde un gars il a
démarré l'année magnifiquement il a mis
une chemise magnifique tu luiques
l'année non mais c'est vrai quoi les
gens sont heureux mais Annabelle je
comprends ce que tu dis et tu as raison
de dire les choses il y aura quand même
deux TR bonnes nouvelles les Jeux
Olympiques on va gagner le tir àarc
euh çair après voilà les Jeux Olympiques
c'est pareil ça va pas être ce qu'on
esconte des Jeux Olympiques pour moi ne
sera pas
complètement a des mauvaises nouvelles
là en fait en que tu vois il y a rien il
y a pas une bonne nouvelle que vous
pouvez nous donner truc sympa TR truc
sympa je sais pas c'est c'est pas une
année simple on va traverser on là quand
même des périodes difficile mais qui
vont nous permettre aussi de d'aller
vers une transformation une évolution
d'autres prise de conscience on a besoin
de passer par là aussi d'accord tu
penses qu'on est passé obligé de passer
par là ah ben ouais tout à fait euh sur
diverses chroniqueurs ici au T de la T
euh est-ce que tu vois des choses que
est-ce que tu vois des choses pour ma
personne également est-ce que tu penses
que je vais changer de slip euh bah la
dernière fois j'avais vu un problème
juridique on avait parlé bah tu vois ça
a été réglé voilà j'ai gagné hein ouais
ah mais il y aura encore quelque chose
qui va arriver ah merde corp juridique
ouais mais ça va mais ça va aller je
vois pas quelque chose qui va
franchement j'ai une batterie d'avocat
je l'ai dit à chaque fois
[Rires]
ah je te jure Annabelle c'est horrible
euh sinon qu'est-ce que tu vois pour on
va dire les gens qui nous intéressent
euh Gil Verdez encore vivant 2024
toujours vivant toujours debout toujours
la banane bien sûr non tu vois un truc
pour lui il va le positif oui il y a une
question je Gil s bah te pose une
question Mar il en a rien à du
couple
que
çaer frère ça fait 2 ans que tu es sur
une pente comme ça frère à la fin c'est
le Tirolien du Juste Prix tu vas tomber
très
haut après c'est quand même elle a une
personnalité assez forte quand même
parce que je vois une une femme a quand
même du tempéramentelle est n oui je
confirme voilà et je sens quand même que
voilà il y a quand même des haut débat
c'est quand même pas toujours si facile
que ça mais j'ai une continuité dans la
relation même s'il y a eu peut-être une
période un petit peu compliqué ces
derniers temps pour moi quelque chose
qui euh redémarre et je vois quelque
chose qui perdureelle en fait ce qu'il
est en train de te demander tu penses
qu'elle va aller avec lui ou qu'elle va
rester avec T
Pier non toute façon moi je vois une
continuité dans la relation il y a par
mais il y a des moments qui sont quand
même un peu voilà besoin d'être voyant
elle va pas lâcher un pigeon comme
ça je te le dis pas besoin d'une boule
de cristal je peux te dire j'ai besoin
de rien mais tiens lui il va rester avec
son mec lui il mais ça on en a déjà
parlé
ou vous m'aviez pas donné de Bonne
Nouvelle est-ce que 2024 ça s'arrange
grec après j'ai pas dit que ça serait
tout de
suite séparation pour moi il y a quelque
chose qui continue dans la relation mais
à un moment donné quand même voilà il y
a une autre personne que je vois arriver
alors t'emmerde pas je t'exlique mais
est-ce que Cyril sera mon pigmalion
cette année c'est parce que je vais lui
bouffer le cul non j'ai besoin moi j'ai
besoin de mots simples les mecs je suis
pas pas ça déjà pas vraiment vraiment
mer descendre merci Annabelle un amour
mais mais en revanche il y a aussi
quelque chose qu'on va vous proposer sur
un je sais pas ça vaêtre une une
émission un peu jeu quel ch va faire le
panda dans
mastinger être reconnu par son
[Applaudissements]
mec c'est en plus c'est
possible elle est forte pourquoi je dis
moi je sais pas mais je sens qu'elle est
forte tu as préparé un truc on passe à
Kelly ah non mais ça
qu'est-ce a quand tu as proposé un truc
alors je vais te dire tu sais moi je
vais te dire bravo Annabelle d'ailleurs
parce que tu tu me détectes les
traîes c'est très important de Me
détecter les traîtres c'est très
importantabelle c'est très important
donc on t'a proposé quelque chose tu le
dis pas tu la vérité à moi non il a
pensé à un truc dans sa tête c'est juste
que je il y a quelque chose qui dans ma
tête mais tu bah ça vait plus dans ta
tête ça va être dans la mienne alors
vas-y dépêche-toi je on verra ça Disle à
K me le dira non Disle à Kell me le dira
pas un rebelle aujourd'hui et droit dans
les yeux
je cass les Rebell c'est juste les
rebelles de ton genre cuir je je
t'exlique dis-moi
l'istoireule dis-moi la vérité
c'est il va pas répéter formule bien ta
phrase formule bien ta phrase attention
cache le micro c'est important il va le
dire dans 2
secondes caches le micro putainou ça tu
sais c'est mais ah ouais on sait pas du
coup on peut savoir vie est pleine de
surpris j'avais dit en fait savoir non
je peux pas le dire il peut pas ça c'est
bien ou pas mais 2024 se faire les amis
on lui a proposé de jouer dans un d'un
truc une série de TEF qui va arriver
pour moi ça va se faire cy et si mal que
ça ah non non il va il va certainement
jouer dans ma touf
[Applaudissements]
tétouf en tout cas pour moi il a çair fa
mais vraiment sur T non non je peux pas
dire ça reste entre nous alors vraiment
ça reste entre nous je ne le DIRIS pas
je peux pas le dire à chaque fois qu'on
secret tout le temps balancé
c'est par c'est vraiment un
am alors si je peux donner un conseil
mais tu vas pas le faire tu vas pas le
fairerou c'est marrant que qu'elle y
pense ça montre quand même son talent
mais attendez c'est logique s'il fait
jurer dans ma singer monsieur rier il va
faire un truc sur moi il va faire un
animal quelconque mais pas du tout c'est
pas
ça du tout çaand c'est trop évident ça
pas de
sens c'est pas ça est-ce que vous
trouvez que c'est une bonne ou une
mauvaise idée il vient dire une très
mauvaise
idée y a rien vous pourriez le produire
ou pas est-ce que vous pourriez le
produire alors j'ai déjà c'est perdu
assez d'argent comme
ça non non non bien sûr mais pour
l'instant il est très bien ici s tu vois
pas que c'est une connerieouff de toute
façon je partirai pas d'ici et pu plus c
m'a proposé de faire toute la semaine à
longueur de temps dès le lundi ouais là
tu étais juste là pour parler de
mainger est-ce que est-ce que tu vois
des choses pour une personne ici bah euh
Valérie moi j'aime non c'est vrai oh
Valérie et oui benï mais oui oui ne dis
pas qu'elle est en train
de parce que je sais qu'il y un projet
ah bah oui il y a des projets il y a des
beaux projets pour Valérie d'ailleurs
c'est une très belle année 2024 ne me
dis pas ah bravo c'est TR endu ce qu'
dit c'est TR ouais il y a des nouveaux
projets d'ailleurs
euh il y a des nouveaux projets nouvelle
émission que jeis arver qu' encore
littéraire euh il y a beaucoup de choses
autour du littéraire ouais pour cette
annéeou bah j'ai un livre qui sort ou
ouais ah ouais va amener de nouvelles
propositions par rapport à à l' à
l'audiovisuel et et je sens quelque
chose qui va aller vers peut-être plus
d'indépendance justement une
[Rires]
émission il a un bon projet
hein c'est génial et franchement anné
très belle année c'est fou ça ouais je
croez pas en lavoyant comme ça non mais
non mais moi je suis contente en tout
cas et euh juste de la tour du pain euh
elle va rester chez nous bien oui je la
vois rester ah tu vois je pas tra moi ça
va tu vas partir il y a quelque chose
qui va évoluer par rapport à l'émission
ah ouais ou ouais je pense
l'horaire ça va être entre 3h et 5h du
matin je un peu plus sur la tête de ma
mère c'est une question professionnelle
Annabelle le projet de faire une
émission oui par Guillaume Janton une
émission de mode c'est pas moi qui
produise c'est Nous Deux ma
gueule donc produite par
C sur la mode et je voulais savoir si ça
allait se faire moi qui produise ouis
alors c'est un projet qui est déjà là
depuis un petit moment quand même
générement quelque chose auquel vous y
pensez déjà depuis un momentuis quelques
mois ou voilà et alors ça prend un petit
peu de temps je vois pas tout de suite
tout de suite mais c'est quelque chose
qui va se mettre en place d'accord et
vous pensez que ça va se faire cette
année je le verrai peut-être plus sur
fin de l'année ça jeai pas dans l'immédi
mais pour moi il y a une réalisation et
je vois quelque chose avec beaucoup
d'originalité quelque chose un peu
atypique je sais pas comme si on
montrait même un espèce de décor ou
quelque chose en fait qui sort de
l'ordinaire ben merci franchement je
dire c'est tout tu as d'autres trucs à
dire parce que j'ai quand même des trucs
à faire sinon tu peux revenir demain
pour les autres demain pour les autres
pour Kelly pour Ron tout ça tu
reviendras demain ou m'a dit un truc
très positif quoi dit tu vas arrêter les
UV ce que une année aussi qui est un peu
non mais tu leur diras demain Montiel
Kelly tout ça vous revenez demain non
bah bah si tu non mais c'est moi qui
décide ce mec vas-y tu seras là demain
par au Maroc tu seras là demain toi tu t
un truc à faire demain non non demain ma
gueule hein tu avais un truc à faire
demain non franchement non dis la vérité
non bah tu seras là demainord comme ça
elle fera toi feras Kelly Kelly tu es là
demain B ouais je suis là demain moi oh
un peu plus
d'enthousiasme tu toi je suis trop
contente d'être là demain en fait voilà
toi tu es là demain bon tu es là demain
aussi bien sûr to tu es là demain par
contre c'est on coproduit le truc de J
on partage
le lui il voulait pas lui je crois qu'il
voulait pas du tout je pense qu'il y a
très forte chance que ça se fasse pas
allez merci Annabel d'avoir été avec
nous les Chéries on va revenir vous
revenir demain pour les autres plair tu
es toujours la bienvenue ici ma chérie
et si tu as des trucs à dire tuhésites
pas tu lèves la main si tu vois un flash
tuis tuas un truc bam tu le dis com
c'est tu as pas de flash là ah ben après
des flash j'en ai tout le temps des
flashas un flash flash h intéressant bah
après voilà ah tu as eu un flash sur mon
tien oui
labord
merciz j'ai un flash sur sur le le
domaine affectif non et oui oui et je
pense qu'il y a une année qui a étaéit
un petit peu difficile enfin voilà on
sent quelque chose qui a é compliqué sur
le domaine affectif et moi je vois une
nouvelle personne qui arrive il a pas
baissé son C depuis
88 ouou il une nouvelle personne il a
une belle belle rencontre qui arrive tu
as rencontré quelqu'un la dernièrement
parce que non ou mais il y a une belle
rencontre qui va arriver k a le dossier
non non je rencontré person si si
apparemment il a pas vu que apparemment
tu as pas vu que des cfte au Maroc
apparemment tu as pas vu que des kfte au
Maroc non non elle me disait non elle me
disait que j'allais en faire rencontrer
quelqu'un peut-être et tu es sur un BA
là tu es sur une meuf ou pas et elle me
parlait non rien du tout elle me parlait
de non non elle me parlait de de métier
surtout de métier le flash sur un job et
c'est métier tu vas tu vas être plombier
je pense
mais je sais pas éviction d'ici oui
ouais ouais non il y a une nouvelle
émission une nouvelle émission
excuse-moi tout le monde a des nouvelles
émissions oui il y a des en tout cas
c'est la vérité il y a une nouvelle
émission des choses qui se prépent sû V
pas faire chez eux leion
juste que je tap
aprs merci ma chérie